Russia's military conscription policy
is about to get more strict.
The Kremlin wants more men
ready for battle.
Like these troops
you see training here in Belarus
The tough
new measures
include electronic delivery of m
call up papers.
Even if a conscripted Russian
doesn't log on to look at those
the government
will still consider him notified
And that makes evasion
all but impossible.
Let's bring in CNN contributor
and former Moscow
bureau chief Jill Dougherty.
And, Jill,
Russian is officials,
I believe, are denying that this
kind of lays the groundwork
for a fresh mobilization.
The Russians must be concerned.
Nevertheless, here.
Well, the indications that we ha
are that they indeed are because
of what happened last September.
You remember
it was a partial mobilization an
if not hundreds of thousands of
left the country very quickly
to avoid that and it was, you kn
a bureaucratic nightmare
because there was chaos
in a long lines of traffic
and people trying to get out.
So that is the explanation
that the Kremlin is giving,
which is nothing
particularly exciting about this
This is a bureaucratic step
to make sure we have a better
unified military register.
And I think what we've got here,
obviously, is of great sensitivi
by the Kremlin.
Even about the word mobilization
because of what happened last ye
And you can
imagine that many young people
would be very worried
if there were another mobilizati
that could send them to Ukraine.
Indeed.
And the timing I mean,
the timing of this is important,
because what we have seen,
at least from our teams on the g
here, Jill, in eastern Ukraine
is, you know,
we're seeing a military
basically bleeding manpower
as well as weaponry and failing
to make any major gains
we were talking about
the east of Ukraine here
Correct.
And then we also have
what's expected
to be this upcoming
counteroffensive by the Ukrainia
And so Russia wants to rush
as many people
into the battle as they can.
And this is spring mobilization
They are always twice a year
call young men up.
And, you know, it's an interesti
I was watching some video
of the discussion in parliament.
There are two houses
lower and high and upper.
And in the lower house,
there was only one person
who actually did not vote for th
And she's an interesting politic
She's the mother of Ksenia Sobch
If you remember her,
who actually ran for president
against Vladimir Putin a few yea
And her name is Ludmila Now Russ
And she said, look,
we all know what this is about.
And if you try to restrict the r
of Russians,
you can only do that in a time o
And we're still not at that poin
in Russia,
where President Putin wants to
describe it
formally as a war because that w
martial law.
So it's a lot of sensitivity abo
and a lot of sensitive internal
internal rifts as well
seem to be playing out.
Jill Dougherty, great to see you
Thanks very much. Still,
there are international concerns
about the welfare of Alexei Nava
a prominent Kremlin critic
who's currently in jail in Russi
The German government
says it's very concerned
about his worsening health
after Navalny spokesperson
said he had severe
stomach issues
and has dramatically lost weight
over the past two weeks.
Vladimir, I should cough
is in the fallen.
The ally
and the executive director
of the Anti-Corruption
Foundation established
by Navalny himself.
He told me
he's getting a little informatio
so far on Navalny's condition.
Have a listen.
Well, our information
flow from the prison where he's
is not very informative.
We learned from his lawyer yeste
that a number was called
to the penal colony
on the night from Friday to Satu
We also learned that
he lost eight kilos over the las
two weeks.
And we
believe that his
health is in serious condition.
It's something related to stomac
He has never had stomach problem
and of course, given the backgro
of his poisoning
by Russia's security services,
this leaves us very worried.
What did the ambulance say?
Any sense of the diagnosis here?
Their lawyer
conveyed to us
that when Navalny asked the doct
what the diagnosis was,
his answer was very elusive.
So we don't have a diagnosis.
Now, you hinted at Vladimir,
which is something that I heard
well from the spokesperson
who said, we do not rule out tha
This time in prison,
he could have been poisoned
with something to make his healt
deteriorate slowly but steadily.
Do not rule out.
Is there any evidence that he ma
been poisoned
Would the symptoms that he has
with that suggest poisoning
any more than acute stomach pain
What more are you learning
We don't have any
more information at this time.
Obviously, in the conditions
of Russian prison,
Russian authorities
and Russian
security services are quite free
to operate as they see fit.
And given the history
of Navalny's poisoning,
we cannot rule anything out.
We don't have any evidence,
any direct
and concrete evidence
about his poisoning.
But you wouldn't you don't rule
And it wouldn't surprise you.
And that order,
would that come from the top?
Would that come from Putin?
Would that come from Prigozhin?
Where would that order?
Who would it come from?
Well, Prigozhin
is a relatively recent
recent figure
in the Russian public space.
When Navalny was poisoned in 20,
a nerve agent, Novichok was used
which was
previously used in Skripal poiso
the UK.
These
agents are only available
to security services
and nobody
can authorize use of such powerf
other than the
top levels of Russian government
which means Putin
and then if it is coming from th
If it is coming from Putin, what
Vladimir,
does this tell us about the divi
the pressures the Kremlin may be
Right now,
right now,
as a sign of weakness
or a sign of strength?
You think if this is what they a
and of course, like you
said, there is no evidence.
I don't
want to overstate
and I don't want to speculate th
the poisoning is taking place.
It's a hypothesis
it is quite plausible,
given the history of Navalny.
But
I think
the reason that decisions
that Russian government
has been taking on making, it's
easier to draft people into the
and
introducing more
and more repressive laws.
I think
it all means that the Russian go
understands that it cannot
achieve victory
on the battlefield in Ukraine
and it needs to tighten
the screws within the country.
So the pressure is mounting.
Clearly,
one of the prison officers I wan
you can shed a bit more light
here, Vladimir.
One of the prison officers
told Navalny this,
according to the spokesperson,
that a provocation
was being prepared against him.
Is this related to what is happe
and how would you interpret a pr
Navalny has been
subject to torture,
and during his two
to over two years, in prison,
often he, an inmate is put into
that has problem with hygiene
or who has just been exposed to
So this is one type of provocati
It's possible
that something
more sinister is being prepared
That's why it's important for us
to share all this information, h
that we get so that the the atte
given to Navalny,
who is arguably the most famous
political prisoner in
the world right now.